well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look there now
what is on the front pages it's time
then to see what is making the headlines
with rachel cunliffe and harry cole
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight and a very good evening
to both of you so to the front pages
then let's start with the metro britain
on a go slow is the lead for that paper
after fuel price protesters targeted
several uk motorways with slow-moving
convoys
according to the mail the home secretary
has ordered police to crack down on any
future such protests it is also the lead
story for the front page of tomorrow's
time get tough they say there
the financial times leads with
predictions of massive
travel disruption from a looming
national rail strike this time involving
the biggest rail union aslef which is
balloting its members on action
the eye reporting on what it calls
growing anger within the cabinet over
having to defend boris johnson again
this time over his handling of the chris
pincher assault allegations
the daily mirror meanwhile leads with
the admission that the pm did know about
previous allegations against mr pincher
before he was appointed deputy chief
whip
while the guardian leads with calls from
two major unions for parliament to act
to stop what they call the seemingly
endless allegations of sexual misconduct
by mps the telegraph says the label
leader sakirstama is facing a party
revolt of his own over his decision not
to take the uk back into the eu if he
becomes prime minister
and the sun has news of the arrest of an
unnamed premier league footballer over
allegations of rape
the express leading with a promise by
boris johnson of massive tax cuts for 30
million people to ease the cost of
living crisis
and the star tells us the lengths some
smokers are going to to find a cheap
substitute for tobacco in these
financially tough times
well quick reminder by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out those front
pages while you watch our guest so let's
go back to harry and to rachel welcome
to both of you
a mixed set of front pages it has to be
said but a number of them harry are
going and the story of the last few days
which is what boris johnson did or did
not know about the man who became his
deputy chief whip um pick us up with the
with the daily mirrors front page then i
did know their headline says
yes so uh downing street's dancing on a
head of a pin if that makes sense um
today or friday they were quite bullish
they said look the prime minister didn't
know any specific allegations despite
the fact that chris pincher had resigned
in 2017 october 2017 as deputy chief
whip over a scandal which we all read on
the front page of the newspapers so
there's a slightly bizarre line on
friday from outside weekly as of daily
lobby briefing that was overhauled uh
should we say to put it uh
to use euphemism um at this morning's
briefing where the prime minister's
spokesman just before the prime minister
was about to go to the house and clearly
wouldn't be able to you know had to give
a honest and truthful account to the
house of commons on what he knew that
line was changed to actually well while
he didn't know any any outstanding
pacific um complaints obviously he was
aware of
as lots of people in westminster have as
mainly because it's been written in the
newspapers and been across the media
that this this man had a bad reputation
they basically said well we kind of knew
about it but we did we thought it was
all fine i mean we hired him anyway
essentially so not a great place for um
for the farmers to be i just if you come
out on thursday and give it in to the
completely inevitable situation that
chris pincher was going to have the whip
removed needed to have the whip removed
and that and that sort of ruthlessness
the private relax again and again and
again in the fact he tries to stick to
people who have been loyal to him
through the years when anyone from the
outside can see they need to be
jettisoned and jettisoned quickly when
they're when they're shown to be a
wronger yeah and this is the problem
isn't it um
rachel that this overhauling of what it
said happens again and again don't say
if you might need to change your story
and this is exactly what has landed the
pm in hot water over his partygate
denials and has led the eye to say that
cabinet members are now um fed up at
having to come out and defend
decision-making
yeah you have to feel sorry for some of
the cabinet ministers who have put up
for the broadcast rounds to defend
whatever the the latest thing that the
government is being criticized for that
day whether it's partygate whether it's
uh not instituting a a windfall tax on
oil companies for the cost of living
crisis whether it's owen patterson
whether it's another pest minister to
scandal whatever it is they go on the
airwaves with it with a line of what
they're meant to say and sometimes by
the time they're they're off air the
government line has changed and i think
that they're being put in an
increasingly difficult position because
these are mps who are having their own
reputations and their own credibility
and integrity torn to shreds by taking
the line that they are told to take
which then turns out not to be the
government's line after all and there
have been some truly astounding lines uh
coming uh out as a result of the the
chris pincher scandal there was one
excuse that boris johnson might have
known about some of the rumors but
couldn't not give him a job based on
that because that would have been unfair
from an hr perspective because they
hadn't been substantiated there was
another one that he had to balance up
these allegations of inappropriate
conduct with pincher's skills which i
think is just a
a blatant insult to all of the very
talented and very dedicated conservative
mps who are not sex pests um
and i think harry's right in that this
was
inevitable and the
four-day attempt to brush it under the
carpet well he's resigned he's an
honorable guy let's all move on we all
knew where this was going uh although
what i didn't see coming was that
tonight the prime minister's own wife or
someone on her team would be briefing
against him by saying that that she knew
that carrie johnson knew of um rumors of
inappropriate conduct about chris benson
back in back in 2017 and and clearly
someone on her team has been briefing
that tonight so a bit of an
uncomfortable position in uh in in boris
johnson's flat tonight i imagine yes
that part of the story uh found out by
our political editor beth rigby in fact
but um you know there's two issues here
if we look at the guardian harry one
what does parliament do about it and the
guardian's main story is that parliament
must act to stop the seemingly endless
allegations of sexual misconduct by mps
and secondly what does it say about the
judgment of the prime minister that
despite knowing of some of these
allegations we're still willing to put
somebody in post in a role that actually
safeguards conservative mps as part of
their
job yeah i just want to point there i'd
fundamentally disagree with with rachel
on one thing though in the fact that
these cabinet ministers they aren't
children they aren't you know they are
sentient beings they could turn around
and say hang on no i'm not going to go
on television until i have spoken to the
prime minister himself and i am
comfortable with the answer there's this
ridiculous line that seems to be seeping
into our politics of oh i haven't seen
that oh i'm just the minister that's on
the monday morning round or on the
sunday shows but no i haven't read the
sunday papers i don't know anything in
them and it's frankly insulting that and
it's nonsense and it's dishonest
actually i think it's for the for the
minister themselves to say actually
until they're comfortable with the line
until they know that they aren't going
to be sort of thrown to the walls 10
minutes later by a u-turn they shouldn't
be on the television they shouldn't be
talking to the voters and i think you'd
actually you'd have seen downing street
up its game
a significant amount in a very short
period of time if a few cabinet
ministers and a few ministers and a few
mps actually stood up to them rather
than just blindly chasing the the whiff
of uh promotion by being slavishly loyal
and dogged by going to the airwaves and
spouting the spouting nonsense and
that's why i think actually scandals
like this one take the entire party uh
the entire conservative party because
everyone has known chris pinscher has
been had these allegations swirling
around them some of them being made
public on the record by named people
former conservative candidates you know
he's been through as we find out tonight
various complaints procedures yet
actually everyone just pretended
everything was fine well actually it's
not fine and you know the amount of you
know bar
the level of
proof we have to get to in order to
publish some of these allegations or
broadcast them on the television is
extremely high when actually people have
known the reality of that and have
frankly covered this up for years
uh 30 seconds quickly rates your front
page of the daily express um do we spot
a bit of whatever it's called
diversionary tactics is it red meat or
something um tax cuts a lot of them tell
us more
well i think it's hoping the voters will
have amnesia so yes there are tax cuts
or cap cuts to a national insurance
coming up just after the government
increased national insurance uh in in in
april raising the tax burden to its
highest level in peacetime so great that
the daily express has forgotten about
that but i think uh
quite quite blatant to try and sell it
as a tax cut when you're you're just
redressing
an increase in tax from a couple of
months previously
both of you stay there we've got lots
more to discuss running out of time i
know already rachel harry stand by we'll
have more on the news that labor leaders
are chris darma is facing revolt of his
own back with that in just a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview uh with me now rachel
conniff deputy online editor at the new
statesman and the sun's political editor
harry cole welcome back to both of you
um rachel talk us through the daily
telegraph then secure stamina clashing
with his own party after his big brexit
announcement today
well he's done a big speech on labour
and brexit
the details of which the label was
actually quite secretive about them
normally you get lots of briefing notes
and and i think the reason they were a
bit secretive about them
was because he hasn't really said all
that much he said that labour wouldn't
uh seek to rejoin the eu it wouldn't
seek to even
have britain rejoin the single market or
the customs union um it would just find
a way to to make brexit work which i
think at this stage is something but we
would all very much like if brexit could
uh start working um but it's interesting
because people like uh arch brexiteer uh
daniel hannon uh have have been saying
that actually britain should have stayed
in the single market all along and the
art form of brexit is too hard so it's
interesting to have her
sorry
that's not what dad hannah said
he he he did he he worked he's always
been he's always been an advocate he's
always been an advocate for saying
if i could finish a sentence i actually
edited dan hannon writes a number of
pieces uh in the run-up to the eu
referendum about how one option for the
uk would be to stay in the single market
uh and uh
adopt that approach with the eu so i
don't think it's entirely genuine to say
that he's never argued on that point but
i'm sure we'll discuss kirsten's
position on brexit a bit later on okay
just i'm gonna cut in just very briefly
that the local police highland park
chief of police in this uh chicago
suburb shooting has said they have now
identified the person of interest in
that
shooting uh robert e crema the third we
understand he is 22 years old and local
to the area we'll have the very latest
on that i'm just going to show you the
last couple of papers we wanted to talk
about
which is pretty patel it's the get tough
message is it not harry in the daily
mail arrest the protest mob this is
after the ghost slow and then the other
story you want to talk about is the fact
that british airways is axing flights
for up to 105 000 holidaymakers this
month uh all of that slightly curtailed
by our breaking news but rachel harry
thank you both very much indeed we'll
see you for the top of the 11. thank you